breaking news tonight The Associated
Press reports the Border Patrol has made
32 arrests at the demonstration at the
border separating San Diego from Tijuana
Mexico tonight we have new evidence of
the lengths some migrants will go to
enter the u.s. this comes as thousands
of other travelers are postponing or
abandoning their quest of course pilot
Steve Harrigan shows us tonight from
Tijuana the desperation of some can only
be guessed at what would drive parents
to drop small children from an 18 foot
border wall injuring one or to push an
eight month-old baby through a hole dug
under the same wall they've come 2,000
miles north by foot or bus carrying
everything they own stalled now in
squalid Tijuana shelters with a
months-long wait for a chance of asylum
in the u.s. record numbers have crossed
illegally Border Patrol says 51 thousand
were arrested in the month of November
alone an increase over the same period
last year of 78 percent thousands
disgusted by the filth and the weight
have given up and gone back home but for
some home is no longer an option no I
don't want to go back it's too much
threat and they try to recruit me
the frustration boiled over for a few
hours two weeks ago when migrants tried
to storm the border the temporary border
shutdown proved so costly to both sides
a new camp was set up 11 miles further
south concrete has replaced mud and
donations have somewhat improved
conditions there's a big need for
underwear because there are no washing
machines here so we were given away
underwear and socks many of the migrants
are finding a middle ground
staying in Tijuana where there's a
strong labor market and trying to move
out of the shelters but patience has
worn thin the violence though limited to
one day has hurt local business and been
a drag on tourism pay it one of the
giant factories here it's about $75 a
week Bret Steve thank you